[música]
al mismo tiempo, se puede decir que el corazón es
cuando operé a mi primer paciente
quien vino aquí fue un niño 6
años
herida de metralla en el cuello
Lo logramos, él está vivo.
[música]
[aplausos]
Bueno, obtenemos todas las drogas que necesitamos.
lo necesitamos, ya se nos acaba el tiempo
hoy prometieron llevarnos allí
tabletas de fundación benéfica
estamos esperando que vengan hay tal pan
los niños necesitan algunos jugos
porque bombardean todo el tiempo y
La advertencia de ataque aéreo está activada y necesitamos
baja al sótano aquí estamos nosotros también
recibiendo tratamiento en el sótano
[música]
[aplausos]
antes el agua era agradable
Su fuerza no es algo de Dasin Tur.
Un nuevo pie pisó el sábado y así
pregunta
[música]